GREAT TO SEE YOU.
AND THEN RUNNING FOR
REELECTION NEXT YEAR?
>> I CANNOT FOCUS BOTH ON
EVERY ELECTION AND THE
CONGRESS IN A BROADER FIGHT
NATIONWIDE THIS IS NOT THE END
OF MY POLITICAL FUTURE.
>> HE WAS TO HAVE BROADER
NATIONAL MUCH MORE IMPORTANT
THAT WEIGHT IS NOT THE REAL
REASON IS THAT THE FACT THE
ANNOUNCEMENT CAME JUST HOURS
TO FIGHT THAT COMPETITIVE
PRIMARIES THOSE THAT WOULD'VE
BEEN FIGHTING FOR THE SEAT GOP
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATE WHAT
DO YOU THINK SO YOU WILL BE
FACING OFF AGAINST KENSINGTON?
>> THIS GUY EMBODIED
EVERYTHING THAT WAS WRONG WITH
ELECTED OFFICIALS A CAREER
POLITICIANS SPENDING THE LAST
TERM AND CONGRESS BASHING HIS
OWN PARTY INSTEAD OF FIGHTING
AGAINST THE RADICAL
PROGRESSIVE AGENDA.
WHILE WE WERE WAITING TO TAKE
THEM ON WITH A LOT OF SUPPORT
NATALIE AND ILLINOIS THAT
NATIONALLY, I THINK AMERICA IS
HAPPY TO SEE SOMEBODY LIKE HIM
GONE FOR GOOD.
AND IT'S TIME WE HAVE REAL
SERVANT LEADERS BACK IN
CONGRESS THAT WANT TO DO GOOD
WORK FOR THE PEOPLE AND
PROVIDE A VOICE FOR AMERICANS.
WERE COMING UP ON REAL BAD
ISSUES THEY ARE KITCHEN TABLE
ISSUES THAT ECONOMY IS HYPER
INFLATION HE WAS NOWHERE TO BE
FINE ON -┘- TO BE FOUND BIDEN
WAS ON CNN BOOSTING HIS OWN
PROFILE TALKING POORLY BY HIS
OWN PARTY WE HAVE HAD ENOUGH
OF THESE CAREER POLITICIANS
AND WE NEED REAL SERVANT
LEADERSHIP.
STEVE: THAT IS THE NEW
DISTRICT.
THAT QUICKLY YOU ARE STILL
FIGHTING WILL BE STEALING
CONGRESS?
>> ABSOLUTELY CATALINA FOR
CONGRESS.COM WE HAVE OVER
$1 MILLION AND THEN TO BRING
BACK POSITIVE CHANGES WE ARE
NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
STEVE: YOU'RE ALWAYS